Just because Charlotte's wounds are deep, it
doesn't suit my testimony to just wait for time to heal.Charlotte:
Yes, instead of a punching bag, instead of a punching
bag,
hit me.Yes, didn't you
hear me? Hit me.  I
heard you say that, but Mr. Wang, did you have a hobby like that
?Don't get me wrong.This
is part of the reason why I can't go.Charlotte, you
can do that to your heart's content.I'm
indebted to Charlotte Allen.
I can't even punch you.
[Music]
What's that? Your glove moves on its own and it's
magic. You
manipulated your right arm to make me hit you. It's like a
professional boxer's aviation screen.
Charlotte tried to recreate the punch and it was a good punch.What on
earth is Mia being shown
?